[Music]
a marching band
and the duke and duchess of cambridge
not your usual monday night
on this cul-de-sac in badly this just
one of william and kate's
christmas surprises their festive
journey had actually started at houston
station on sunday night
transport workers the first that they
wanted to thank
it's moments like we've had this year
that ever appreciates you know what you
guys do
you feel much
they borrowed the queen's train for this
rare nationwide journey
allowing them to wake up in edinburgh
the palace stressed that it was
a working visit to scotland and so
within the travel restrictions
as they met emergency workers to talk
about the pressures
of covet 19. their thank you
tour will see them travel over 1 200
miles in two days
between scotland england and wales
a quick hop across the border and holy
trinity school in beric pontuide
to recognise the hard work of teachers
with reindeer
courtesy of the palace
[Music]
next stop was batley in yorkshire and
time for kate to meet
a friend that she'd made during lockdown
as a volunteer she'd talked to
85 year old len gardner on the phone and
even sent him
a pasta machine william and kate offered
to take him home
so they could meet his wife shirley who
has dementia
and join them for a little dance
you just can't find the correct words to
explain the day like this
it's probably a day that not many people
will experience
um and i actually never forget it
obviously
what was it like talking to her on the
phone it was like talking to you
really just ordinary talk no
you know after the first sentence which
was i said to her
how do i address you because i like to
do things right
and she says just call me catherine
right across the country people have had
to live with different restrictions
because the pandemic
in different types of tears but one
thing that's always stood out right
across the country are those small
acts of kindness and community spirit
and that's what william and kate
think is more than worth celebrating
one final carol but the locals didn't
really seem to want them to go
tomorrow more stops and more surprises
that they hope
will make the country smile rhiannon
mills
sky news in badly